[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMEER ABBAS: Welcome, everybody.
We are going to talk about
Kubernetes and Spinnaker
and Istio, and how we can
kind of combine all this to do
multicloud.
Who's excited?
Come on.
[CHEERING]
All right.
GKE On-Prem.
Great announcements yesterday.
Hopefully everybody's
conference is going well.
My name is Ameer Abbas.
I am a customer engineer
here in San Francisco,
which basically just means
I help people solve problems
in the cloud.
I've had the privilege of
working with a few of you
actually in the room and a
few customers that have either
embarked on the journey
to this hybrid cloud,
multicloud, or
are already there.
And some of the best
practices that we've
learned kind of together,
I've consumed then
into this session.
And maybe over the
next 30 minutes
or so, 40 minutes,
we'll talk about that.
Here's my Twitter handle.
Somebody told me I've got
to up my Twitter game,
so I think I have
three followers.
So hopefully by the end,
I'll have maybe five.
All right.
So what are we
going to talk about?
We're going to talk
about multicloud and why
organizations are
going multicloud.
Why is this thing kind of
hot and heavy right now?
And how does that affect
people's experiences?
How does that affect your
customers' experience?
company's, your organization's
experience, your developers'
experience, your operators'
experience?
We're going talk about that.
And then we're going to
talk about three things.
We're going to talk about
the architecture itself.
And just for the sake
of this discussion,
we're going to stick
with Kubernetes.
However, there are
multiple definitions
of multicloud and hybrid cloud,
and it goes beyond Kubernetes.
But just to kind
of stay focused,
we're going to talk
about Kubernetes and why
that makes it better.
We're going to
talk about how you
can manage life cycles
of your applications
and then just kind
of talk a little bit
about after your
applications are up,
how do you do connectivity,
and observability,
and how you safely
connect those.
And hopefully-- we've seen
enough sessions today,
so hopefully you guys
where we're going.
So let's kind of just start
at a very high level why
people are looking at this
thing called multicloud.
And if we kind of
step back in time
to the times of data
centers, I have never
stepped into a data center
where I saw a single vendor.
So you didn't just have
Cisco or didn't just
have a single vendor for servers
or a single vendor for storage.
You always had multiple
vendors in there.
And that, I think, trend
continues even in the cloud.
The only challenge
is in the cloud,
you have the owners,
or the cloud owners,
that own your data center.
So in this case, you
have to actually double
your data centers.
Or you have to have multiple
data centers instead
of the other way around.
So the number one
reason we've heard
in terms of why
people go multicloud
is just this idea of
zero vendor lock-in.
Even though cloud provides
you with a lot of resiliency
and availability, but if
you're using managed services
and if one of those
services goes down,
then you're kind of out of luck.
Organizations want more control.
And every cloud vendor does
cost a little bit differently.
Perhaps you have
credits with one cloud
and you want to use those.
So that kind of
comes around a lot.
Resiliency and availability--
I was working with a customer.
They were in a single region.
They decided to go multi-region.
And as I was talking
with them, they
said the benefit that they
got from going multicloud
and the work that
they had to do,
instead of going multi-region
with a single cloud
versus multi-region
with multiple clouds,
was really not that much.
And all those benefits
that they got,
they outweighed the work
that they had to do.
Best of breed services
is usually another one.
So we want to use
multiple clouds
because each cloud is doing
something better than others.
At Google, we're known for
our data services, our ML,
and perhaps you're using some
proprietary services on prem,
so the idea that I want to
be able to use and choose
what I want to use.
And then the last one comes
up maybe not as often,
and it's the idea of technology
and business partnerships.
You don't want to kind of hedge
your bets with a single vendor.
And perhaps you want to
have multiple integrations
in multiple environments.
Really, it comes down
to, in one word, choice.
Whether you're looking
as a business owner
or whether you're looking at
it from a technical standpoint.
A lot of the things that we
talked about here previously,
you can think of them
as business reasons
why people go multicloud
or multi-cluster
in that particular range.
But when we look at it from
a developer's standpoint,
it really comes down
to freedom of choice.
So a developer's
productivity is directly
correlated to the
services that they can use
and they can choose.
So if I'm a developer,
and if I want
to use BigQuery, or Spanner,
or any of the open source
products, or any of the
other managed services,
regardless of where
they're located,
I just need a safe
passage to get there.
And I don't really
care how I get there,
I just want to be able
to describe what I want
and magically it
just appears to me.
Choice leads to chaos.
The more choice you
have, the more things
are a little bit different.
They're heterogeneous.
And as operators, as DevOps,
we don't like heterogeneity.
Because that leads
to something unsafe.
It slows everything down, and
we want to be fast at iterating.
So the question comes, and
I get asked this a lot,
should I be using
platform as a service?
And it's a great question.
And perhaps you start with
a single platform and even
a platform as a
service, and then you
decide where you want to go.
The challenge in general
with platform as a service
is they're very
opinionated systems.
So they kind of go
inversely proportional
to the idea of
developer's choice.
So you may start
with a platform,
and you may kind of
lock your developers
into what they want to do.
And then eventually
your developers
are going to want
something else.
And then all of
a sudden, you are
getting into this
heterogeneous world anyways.
So this is a cultural
type of a tipping point,
that you have to
decide where you
are at that particular case.
Let's switch focus just for a
minute to DevOps and operators.
So in a very high level
way, our jobs as operators
is to take something
that's chaotic,
and take something
that's heterogeneous
and that's running in
these hybrid environments,
push it through some
magic box, and then
out comes something very safe,
and sound, and homogeneous,
because we like that.
That's what we want to get to.
And what goes in that circle
is what's in our opinion.
We can make an
opinion about that.
I want to take a
quick segue and talk
about these two words that
are in the middle, culture
and tooling.
And I really want to start
with this idea of tooling.
Whenever a new tool comes out,
like Kubernetes for example,
and all of a sudden it
gains a lot of hype,
everybody wants
to do Kubernetes.
I don't even know
what that means.
Like, when people say,
we need to do Kubernetes,
it just became a
verb or something.
And then we force our
organizations, our people,
our culture to kind of
adhere to that tool.
I think we're
doing it backwards.
I think what we
need to do is kind
of sit down with our business,
with our business goals,
and figure out exactly what
culture we want-- what culture
of development we want, what
culture of iteration we want,
what culture of
deployment we want,
and then pick the tools
that match that culture.
And I think that's also
the reason why tools also
get a lot of mixed reviews.
Because what we're
doing is we're
trying to use a tool which
it wasn't meant to do.
And we'll talk about that
here a little bit later.
So let's get back to
our regularly scheduled
programming.
So talking about operators
and talking about DevOps here,
where developers
need more choice
and their productivity
really hinges on the services
that they can get to, it's our
job to get them there safely.
The journey is
under our control.
We can't really control
the destination,
but we can control the journey.
And I think that's
our true calling,
is to make sure
that we give them
that golden path, that
safe passage, there.
And what goes in that middle
box of automation and control
and tooling, that's
something that we
can be opinionated about.
And that's something
we can talk about.
So a lot of people ask where
all these pieces fit in.
So we have Kubernetes,
and Spinnaker, and Istio.
What does that mean?
And do I need all
of these things?
So this is kind of a simple
visual of where I think
everything kind of fits in.
So at the very bottom, you
have your business logic
that you convert into
code as a developer.
And you need a way
to package that.
And containerization
gave us that.
And we don't need to really
talk anything more about that.
I think we've been talking
about that to death.
So containerization gives
us a great, efficient way
to package our code.
Then as you start deploying
containers in production
at scale, you need some
sort of an orchestrator,
some sort of a control
plane that manages that.
And that's where
orchestration comes in.
It's a way to run
your applications.
Now that you have your
applications running,
you need to manage the
lifecycle of those applications,
and that's where CI/CD tooling,
so continuous integration,
continuous deployment, and
delivery tools come in.
And then this last
thing which we're
going to talk a little bit more
about later is this idea of now
that we have hundreds, maybe
thousands of containers
running, how do we securely
connect and monitor
and manage the
connectivity of that?
And that's where the concept
of service mesh comes in.
And where some of
these tools fit in
is something that
looks like this.
We think Kubernetes is the best
place to run your containers.
And we'll talk about why
that is and why it's really
gaining a lot of hype in
the developer community,
especially.
Spinnaker, again, is
one of those tools.
It's a continuous
deployment tool.
We'll talk about that.
And especially,
we'll talk about that
in the realm of multicloud
and hybrid cloud.
And then some of
you may have heard
of Istio, which is an
implementation of service mesh
that allows us this kind of
a safe passage from container
to container.
Now, two things I want to
say about this picture.
One, first of all, I
think this forms a very
formidable platform for you.
It's built of open source things
that you can deploy anywhere.
You don't have to have
every single component
that you see here.
You start with
something kind of basic.
As a matter of fact,
a lot of the times,
the journey starts with just
a platform, a Kubernetes
or an orchestrator
of your choice.
And then you just make sure
that you can do that well
and you can do that better
before you kind of move
onto these tooling.
Another thing about this is
that a lot of these things
you can slide out and insert,
bring your own orchestrator
or bring your own CD tool.
You're not stuck
with these things.
We're just talking
about them as examples,
because these kind of fit
well in the multicloud space.
But you can slowly go
through this journey,
and you can exchange
these LEGO pieces to what
makes the most sense to you.
Because I do get asked
a lot of questions
about Spinnaker versus Cloud
Build and stuff like that.
And again, it's a spectrum.
It just depends upon what you
want out of your, let's say,
continuous deployment tool.
Or service meshes,
we've been doing them.
It was just called routing
and switching and firewalls.
And why do we need service mesh?
Again, it just depends upon
what you're trying to do.
So let's maybe start at
the bottom of the stack,
and kind of work our way
up, and then just see
how this all fits together.
And then maybe we'll
even talk a little bit
about the journey of it.
So Kubernetes, in
one sentence, it's
a way for developers to
describe their workloads.
And it just makes it happen
through a consistent API.
So it completely abstracts
you from cloud resources.
Your application
is a combination
of a bunch of resources.
There's VPCs and routing
and firewall rules
and VMs and load balancers.
All of that combined,
your application
is kind of hidden
in there somewhere.
And Kubernetes gives
us that consistent API
where developers can just
say, this is what I want done.
This is my desired state.
And what works well
with Kubernetes
is if you're in
heterogeneous environments
or hybrid environments,
it will abstract you.
The way you do networking
on prem versus the way GCP
does networking, you don't
have to think about that
as a developer anymore.
You can simply describe it
in a very consistent way,
and it will just make it happen.
As you start expanding, you may
start with a single cluster.
You'll probably end up
becoming multiple clusters,
whether it's in single cloud.
So in this picture,
let's say you
start with a single
cluster, multi-tenant,
then eventually you go to
multiple clusters in GCP.
Then you have some clusters
on prem, perhaps GKE On-Prem.
And then we have this one
cluster in some orange cloud
that no one's ever heard of.
So we start thinking about how
we're going to manage this.
So first concept I want to talk
about is cluster consistency.
So the idea is kind of
similar to API consistency
with Kubernetes.
If we have multiple clusters,
if we configure them
in a consistent way, not only
do I get workload portability,
but I also get a consistent
way to describe my workload.
So if I'm a developer and I can
go around and I'm traveling,
and let's say I just want to
get connected to my closest
cluster, I just want to be
able to describe my workload.
And through the
magic of routing,
I should be able to get
to where I want to go.
And Kubernetes gives
us this concept
of namespaces, which are
just these logical containers
and abstraction
within a cluster that
divides your cluster
into different containers
that you can put authorization
and [INAUDIBLE] on top of that.
So an example here
is, for example,
if I'm a developer perhaps
I have my own namespace.
And I have some resource
quota within that namespace,
where inside of that namespace,
I can do whatever I want.
So I can develop.
I'm free to do whatever I want.
And then, perhaps, teams
have their own namespaces
like my development team
or my engineering team.
And they can collaborate
on top of that.
So a lot of people
ask the question,
when do I need multiple
clusters versus when
do I need namespace separation?
A common theme looks
something like this.
By the way, you don't
need 18 clusters.
This was just easier to cut,
copy, paste three times.
But essentially, an easy
way to think about this
is you will separate out
your phases of development.
So you'll have a separate
cluster or clusters for dev,
separate one for staging,
separate one for prod.
And that's a theme
that we've seen.
And by the way,
this is by no means
an exhaustive list of
what you should do.
This is just some
common patterns
that have emerged as
we're talking to people.
Within an environment, so
within dev, within prod,
within staging, they
look fairly consistent.
And in this case, like I said,
I just cut, copy, pasted it.
However, you may have a
much smaller, let's say,
dev environment, and a
completely different set
of namespaces and permissions
than staging than prod.
And your mileage may vary.
So when you look at
a picture like this,
it looks quite daunting.
And then you start
thinking about, well,
how am I going to manage
all of these things?
And how am I going to
manage applications that
go into all of these things?
So again, going back
to the idea of that
when we find a tool that
we get a lot of force
behind, a lot of
community behind,
immediately we want that tool
to solve all the problems.
So immediately we say, oh, we
need some sort of federation.
That word comes up.
Pretty much in any technology
that I've ever seen,
we need federation.
And we don't even think
about what that means.
A lot of people just say, can
federation solve this problem?
Like, we need some networking
between this pod and this pod.
Can federation
solve this problem?
Or we need cluster management.
Can federation
solve this problem?
So we just immediately want
the tool, which is not,
by the way, designed to
do what it's meant to do.
We want that tool
to solve everything.
So Kubernetes was
really designed
to run containerized
applications
at scale in production.
And that was it.
And then we started
talking about this concept
of federation.
And I don't mean to
talk down on federation.
I'm just kind of delivering
the message of how we typically
think as a community
and how we immediately
start to expand the scope of
what the product's actually
meant to do.
So federation, for those
of us who may not know,
is an API that's abstracted
away from the cluster.
And it kind of gives you a
centralized control plane.
And the hope, or the dream,
is that that federation API
will magically just solve
all of your problems
from networking to
cluster management
to application management.
When you think of a picture
that looks something like this,
and you really look at
some of the use cases
and what are we trying to
do, and you split them up,
it makes a little bit more sense
to see what tool makes the most
sense to solve the problem.
So first thing is the cluster
lifecycle management itself.
How do I manage the policy and
the lifecycle of the cluster?
That's one problem.
Then you have application
lifecycle management.
How do I manage the
applications that actually
get put on top of that?
That's another one.
And then you have kind of
the service, discovery,
cross-cluster, integration,
and that problem.
And we want federation to
solve all of these problems.
And it may be the
right solution.
We don't know.
It may not be the
right solution.
It may be the right solution.
What we're starting
to see, there
were a couple of logistical
problems with the federation
API.
There were only a
handful of people
that were working on the
federation API versus thousands
and thousands of people that
were working on the Kubernetes
API.
And it was just almost nearly
impossible to keep that feature
parity.
And on top of that, when you
have a centralized control
plane and something
goes wrong, it just
cascades across everything.
So when you make one mistake,
it just goes through that.
So whether you call it
cluster independence--
I don't know if that's
a really good name.
I know the community
called it multi-cluster.
Just the idea here is that
if you treat each cluster
kind of isolated islands,
and you just overlaid them
with components and tooling
that gives you cluster lifecycle
management, that gives
you application lifecycle
management, it might be a
better way to do things,
because you can isolate
the blast radius when
something bad happens.
So from a cluster
lifecycle management,
we're not going to talk
too much about that.
I know there's some
announcements coming
with the GKE On-Prem and
multi-cluster management.
Hopefully you saw
some of the demos.
I'm really going to go
into application lifecycle
management and then service,
cross-cluster service
discovery and kind of
traffic management piece.
So let's look at an application
running on Kubernetes.
So again, we have
multiple clusters.
And an application on
Kubernetes is also a combination
of a bunch of resources.
So you have deployments,
and deployments
are running replicas of pods.
So in this case, we
have an application.
Let's say this is a web
front end application running
and two versions of
that deployment running.
We have a red version
and a black version,
three pods running each.
They're upended by
a service, and then
let's say this is
a web front end.
So you're exposing it
out through an ingress.
And since this is
a web front end,
you want that application
running everywhere.
So the picture looks
something like this.
You have a bunch of
these resources that
are kind of distributed across
clusters, across namespaces,
and then if you put a
box around all of this,
that's what your application
actually looks like.
And from a developer's
perspective,
I don't want to go
into each cluster
and start looking at what
my deployment looks like,
what my ingress looks like,
what my service looks like.
So platforms and even
cloud resources in general
are a very
resource-centric-- give you
a very resource-centric
view of your application.
They don't really tell you
what your application is doing.
So hold that thought.
When we go to Spinnaker,
we'll talk a little bit more
about that.
But I really want to talk
about where Spinnaker fits in
in this application
lifecycle management
and how we see CI/CD at Google.
So from converting business
logic into source code,
we have source repository,
to building and unit testing
your artifacts, and that's
where Cloud Build comes in.
Hopefully you've heard some of
the announcements around there.
To artifact storage
through Container Registry,
and that's our own private
container repository,
very similar to Docker
Hub that's backed up
by Cloud Storage.
And where Spinnaker
really fits in
is in the continuous delivery
and continuous deployment
thing.
So that's what Spinnaker
is meant to do.
And again, this is a spectrum.
There are a myriad
of tools that you
can use to manage your
application lifecycle.
And it depends upon
where in your journey
are you in that
particular stage.
So you can use Cloud
Build to do everything
if you don't need, let's say,
automated canary analysis,
which we'll talk
about, or if you
don't need our back integration
with your LDAP and stuff
like that.
So what is Spinnaker?
For those of you
who may not know,
Spinnaker is an
open source tool.
It was open source by Netflix.
It's a continuous
delivery and deployment
tool that works really well
across hybrid and multicloud
environments.
And by hybrid I mean both
in different clouds--
let's say on prem and
GCP or something--
as well as in
different environments.
So you could do
VMs and Kubernetes.
It gives you a very
application-centric view
of your application.
So in this particular example--
this is a screen shot,
one of the screen shots,
of Spinnaker-- we have an
application called MD Service.
And you can see that
right at the top left.
And then I can
see exactly what's
happening with that
particular service.
So that particular service
is running in two clusters.
Those are the red boxes.
I can see which namespaces
they're running on.
So they're running in
the default namespace.
I can see how many
deployments are running.
So in the prod version,
which is the top cluster,
I have one deployment running,
which is kind of the big box.
And then I can also see
the green rectangles
are the individual
pods that are running.
And I can see them
scaling up and down.
And since they're
green, that means
everything is nice and healthy.
Everything is good to go.
And in my staging
cluster, I can see
that I have two pods running.
And I also can keep
track of my existing
iterations of that deployment.
Also, if I click on
any of these resources,
I can get a much more detailed
view of what's going on.
So if I click on
the deployment, I
can see how many
replicas I'm running.
I can even see the
container logs and so on.
Everything in
Spinnaker is deployed
in something called
a pipeline, which
may be not a foreign concept
to a lot of you, which
is, if I want to get from
version 1 to version 2,
I need to go through a
series of steps and actions
that are interdependent.
And they really depend upon
what's happening before.
So this is an example.
And those steps, by the
way, are called stages.
So this is an example of a
fairly common pipeline, where
I've taken something
out of staging
and I want to now
eventually get to production
that particular piece of code.
So I grab that image.
I deploy it as something
called a canary, which
we'll talk about.
I wait a few
minutes to make sure
that that thing is looking good.
If everything passes, then I
promote that to production.
I tear down the old
production, and I tear down
the canary that I've deployed.
And I promote that particular
image to production.
Even though Kubernetes comes
with some elementary way
to manage applications or manage
services like rolling updates
and stuff, perhaps you need
a little bit more horsepower.
And Spinnaker gets
you that extra mile.
So there are
deployment strategies
built in, like red-black,
rolling red-black,
or canary are kind of the
three more popular ones.
So red-black, or sometimes
called blue-green, is the idea
that I have one version
of an application running.
So in this case, we have the
blue version with eight pods
running, let's say.
And then when I want to deploy
a new version, version green,
I also will deploy
in eight pods.
And then I will just flip
the load balancer over.
Great thing is I can very
quickly and immediately
move back to the blue version
if something goes wrong.
And the bad thing is I need
twice as many resources
because I have both versions
running for a period of time.
Kind of the new iteration of
that is the rolling red-black
or rolling
blue-green, which is I
will gradually roll
down one instance
as I bring up the
other instance.
And every so often,
I will just make sure
that everything is
going very smoothly.
And I'll have these
validation gates.
And canary is another
iteration of rolling red-black.
Really, the idea
here is that I will
deploy a canary, a
very small version,
and I will direct production
traffic to that canary.
And then I will test
that canary for a number
of metrics against a baseline
of production traffic.
And then based on
all these metrics,
I will give it a
score, a canary score.
And then if that score is
passable or high enough,
then I will promote
that to production.
And really what
makes it different
is that canary analysis
piece and the idea
that I'm actually sending
production traffic,
and I'm actually comparing
it to production baselines.
Some other things
that are built in
are just the idea that I can
dictate which days and times I
want these pipelines to run.
I can have manual intervention.
So I can say, go to
step C and then pause.
And then let's wait for someone
to actually push the Continue
button.
And I can roll
back quite easily,
because Spinnaker keeps track
of historical views of what's
happening as well.
Lots and lots of
integrations-- these
are just a bunch of logos.
Triggers are a good one.
So you can trigger pipelines.
So you can have all
these templated pipelines
already built for each
application, maybe even
multiple pipelines.
And you just need a
way to trigger them.
So an easy way is anytime a
code changes or a version tag
changes-- and I'll show you
an example of that shortly--
just run the pipeline.
So think of that pipeline
as kind of that paved path
to the next version.
Let's talk a little bit about
Istio and service meshes.
So we have Kubernetes deployed.
We feel very good about just
our Kubernetes environment.
Then we started deploying some
sort of a CD tool or CI/CD,
maybe Spinnaker.
And we feel great.
Now we have multiple versions
of our applications and services
running in multiple
environments.
And all these need to
now talk to each other,
and we don't know
exactly how to do this.
So somebody smart said this.
I still don't know who said
it, but I think very, very wise
words by somebody.
I have no idea how everything
is talking to each other.
And more importantly, I can't
observe exactly what's going on
in this particular thing.
And that's kind of
where Istio comes in.
And before we talk about Istio,
let's spend a few minutes
on service meshes, and
what is a service mesh
and why do we need it?
There was a pretty
big, long sentence,
and then I was just trying to
keep it shorter and shorter.
And this was kind
of the shortest form
of that sentence, which is
transparently automating
network application functions.
Or even more simply, I want
to basically take the business
logic away from any of the
networking functionality.
So anything to do with
networking, security,
observability, I want
to abstract that away
from my core code, my
core business code.
That's really what
a service mesh is.
Lots and lots words
on this slide--
this is not my favorite slide.
You don't have to read it.
But just the four
categories that we kind of
want to mention.
Now that we have multiple
versions of multiple services
running, we want to be
able to control which
version of service A can
talk to which version
of service B, which user
can talk to which front end,
and so on.
So we need some intelligent
and more advanced
routing than what Kubernetes
natively gives us.
Resiliency.
Timeouts.
Circuit breakers is a huge one.
If I have cascading
failures, I want
to be able to open that
circuit for x amount of time,
instead of just that
service going haywire.
Health checks.
Security and policy
is even bigger.
So every service needs to
have some verifiable form
of identifying itself
to other services.
When two services
talk to each other,
I want to be able to tell
with great confidence
that I am who I
am, who I say I am.
And I want to be able
to talk to each other
in an encrypted fashion.
And then policy
enforcement-- perhaps I
want to put limits
on RPS and QPS
and how much rate can one
service talk to another.
Perhaps you have a free
version or freemium
version of a service.
And you can say, I'm
going to rate limit that.
And then you have
a paid version,
and you can open that up.
And then last probably
should be the first,
which is the idea of I also
want to observe and see
exactly what's going on.
So I want to see the
logs and the metrics
and especially distribute
a tracing, which really
kind of comes into being
when you're talking
about multiple clusters.
So a quick history
of load balancers.
Matt Klein wrote a
fantastic blog on Medium.
If you haven't seen it,
I highly recommend it.
It's a little bit
of a long read,
and I'm sure we'll share
these slides with you.
Or you can just type "Matt Klein
history of load balancing."
I'm going to give you the
three-minute version of what
he talks about on kind of where
we were and where we are now.
So the idea, again,
is very simple.
If you look at the top two
versions of load balancing,
they're fairly similar.
I have a bunch of
clients that want
to talk to a bunch of services,
a bunch of back end services.
So I go through a single
gateway, a centralized gateway,
or a proxy, like an F5,
let's say, in a data
center or something like that.
And then it fans out
my requests back,
which means
everything has to talk
to that centralized gateway.
So that second one is kind of
an iteration of that, maybe
internal load balancer
versus external.
The challenge with this--
and that's what we call
server-side load balancing.
The challenge with this is in
a micro services environment
where every service needs
to talk to every service,
you're paying that extra hop.
So if everything is going
to a centralized gateway,
that model may not be
the most efficient.
It may work, again,
for a period of time.
And then eventually,
you'll grow beyond that.
And then you're
paying that extra hop.
So that's where the concept of
client libraries came about,
which is, again, I'm
going to take anything
that I need for
networking, and I'm
going to shove that
into a library.
And then I'm going to
force my developers
to use that library with every
service that they create.
So it works great.
Day one, you have one language,
and you have one version
of the client library.
And you force your developers.
They do a very good job.
And then all of a sudden,
you have multiple versions
of that library in one language.
And then all of a sudden,
you have multiple languages
and multiple versions
of that library.
And oh, by the way, developers
are not networking experts,
are not security experts.
So any of the vulnerabilities
that you have,
they are just going to blindly
put that into their services.
And you have this
very tight coupling
between services and that
networking functionality.
So that kind of gave
birth to this idea
that I want to take all of
this networking and security
and observability, and
I want to run that out
of process, out of my core
service process, as a side car,
or think of it as a valet.
So instead of you
talking directly to me,
you will talk to a valet
and then say, go ahead
and deliver my message.
So now we have an interesting
picture, just at the bottom.
By the way, this is what's
called a client-side load
balancing, where I've taken
all of the load balancing
and routing and
switching functionality,
and I've moved it
out of process.
Now we can draw a line in
between those two services,
and we can have
clear delineation
of roles and responsibility.
Above that line is
my business logic.
My developers can handle that.
That's what they're good at.
Let them do that.
Below that line, our
operators, our network admins,
our DevOps can handle that.
That's what they're good at.
Also, the services at
this point have no idea
of their networking
topology, which
works great in this
multicloud, hybrid cloud,
heterogeneous environments
that we're talking about.
So a way to look at it is,
you have a bunch of services,
and they each have
a side car running.
And visually if you think
about two concentric circles.
You have an outside circle
with all these services,
and then you have an inside
circle with all these proxies.
Outside circle has no
concept of the inside circle
or any of the topology.
You can even just pick that
up and put another one in.
And these proxies are the ones
that are talking to each other.
And the developers are just
kind of sitting on the outside,
just developing and just putting
business logic into code.
So that's one way
of looking at it.
Another interesting
thing about this picture
is it looks very clean.
You have this box
around these two things.
So in this world of
containerization,
these two could
be containerized.
And it should be put
in some abstraction.
And in Kubernetes,
that works really well,
because we have something
called pods that
can run one or more containers.
So in this particular
case, we have one container
running our service
and then one container
running our proxy
or our side car.
And that's where that
concept comes in.
So what is that proxy?
Anybody heard of Envoy?
Half the people, great.
Envoy is a proxy.
At its heart, at its core,
it's just a layer 4 proxy, just
like Nginx, HAProxy.
It has layer 7 filters built in.
It can speak a lot of
different protocols.
It's HTTP/2 first.
It's very scalable,
very resilient.
It's very lightweight.
So the lightweight part makes
it really interesting and really
efficient to work in that.
By the way, you don't
have to use Envoy.
But I just mention that, because
it does a few things pretty
interesting.
So the way you can
figure Envoy at runtime
is through something
called Discovery Services.
And together, they're called
Aggregated Discovery Services,
or ADS.
So Listener Discovery
Service-- what
ports should I be listening
to and how should I
be listening to them?
Route Discovery Services--
how should I route traffic
as it comes in and goes?
Cluster and endpoints,
you can almost
think of them as services and
pods in the Kubernetes lingo.
So a cluster is a
service in Kubernetes,
and endpoints are pods or
endpoints within communities.
And they can discover
that at runtime live.
They don't have to be restarted.
The proxy doesn't
have to be restarted.
Which now brings us to Istio.
Istio is just an open
source implementation
of a service mesh.
You don't need Istio as long as
you have something like that.
Istio uses those Envoy proxies
and gives you all that network
functionality.
And from an architectural
perspective,
what it looks like is
something like this.
And for the past
few minutes, we've
been talking about the data
plane, how the actual data
flows back and forth.
So in this particular
case, every service,
even if it's outside
of Kubernetes,
will run with an
out-of-process proxy.
So in this case, this
is the Envoy proxy
that's running right
below each service.
And the service will never talk
directly to another service.
It will go through
its sidecar proxy,
through the other sidecar
proxy, and then back up.
And then between the proxies
is where all the networking
magic and all those
advance feature
functionality and telemetry,
all of that is happening.
And services have no clue
of the networking topology.
Much like everything
else, we need
a data plane, which we talked
about, and a control plane.
The control plane consists
of three components--
the pilot, the mixer,
and the citadel.
And let's talk about each of
these at a very high level.
The pilot is the deployment
or the service that actually
configures those Envoy proxies.
So it talks to every single
Envoy in your service mesh
and says, this is how
you're constructed.
This is how you need
to talk to each other.
It has kind of a north
side and a south side.
And we talked about
the south side,
which talks to the Envoy API.
So it uses those Aggregated
Discovery Services
to configure the Envoys itself.
And then on the north side, it
uses other service discovery
services.
Like it uses the
Kubernetes API to discover
all the services running.
It also uses Istio configs,
which are custom resource
definitions, to actually--
where you can configure yourself
the route rules,
where you can say,
I want 50% of the traffic
going to version 1 and 50%
to version 2.
It discovers all of that
and then pushes that down
to the Envoys themselves.
So it's responsible for just
configuring the Envoy proxies.
Mixer is kind of the
pluggable things.
It does two things.
It does policy and
quota enforcement,
and it does
telemetry collection.
Itself, it's just a collector.
It's not a logging solution
or a metric solution.
It's an API that exposes these
metrics out to something.
So from an observability
perspective,
those proxies, by
the way, are sitting
at a very fortunate
position, because they
get to see every single
request go through them.
And they can asynchronously
send all these fancy metrics
to something.
In this case, that
something is the mixer.
And then you can plug
in your own solutions
and your own tooling to
abstract all of these metrics
and then display them
however you want.
So for example,
Prometheus has a plug-in
which comes as a part of
an Istio implementation.
Prometheus is a
metrics collector
that connects through a mixer,
collects all the metrics,
and then you can put some
dashboarding solutions
like Grafana or something else.
Stackdriver has a
plug-in where you
can do all of those
things in a single place.
It also does policy
and quota enforcement.
You can have rate limiting
and so on and so forth.
And then citadel
is the last piece,
and that does all
the security stuff.
So it provides
verifiable identity
in the form of Spiffy IDs.
And then it also provides
a mutual encryption.
So the citadel is sort of like
a CA or a certificate authority,
where it's responsible for
distributing certificates,
certification, and
collecting that.
So this is where I
just want to show you
kind of an example of
how this all works.
And let's pray to the demo gods
that everything is working.
Can we please switch to demo?
I was told not to
have screen savers.
OK.
So just to kind of set
the stage on where are,
we have three clusters,
three Kubernetes clusters.
They're all running in GCP.
We have two clusters, one
in central, one in east.
That's going to kind of simulate
our multi-cluster, multicloud
deployment.
And then we have a
third cluster that's
just running our Spinnaker.
So it's just responsible for
just sending applications down
there.
I'm just going to show you
an example of a web app.
It's just a very
simple web app that
takes the version tag
from the application name
and puts it back into
the index HTML file.
So we can just always
see what's running.
And then we can just
curl that application.
So if we just do--
and I'm just going to pick
one of those two clusters,
but it's essentially
the exact same thing.
So if we look at the deployments
on the central cluster,
I have two deployments running.
So I always have
a canary running,
and then I have my prod running.
And the version changes
depending upon--
the version next
is always canary
and the version now is prod.
And I always have
four pods of prod
and one pod of canary running.
So what I'm going to do right
now is just start a curl loop
so you can just kind
see what's going on.
So currently in my GKE central
cluster, I have, in my app,
which is the web front
end, and it's running
version 103 in production.
And now I'm a developer,
and I want to upgrade that.
And I don't really care about
Kubernetes, or Spinnaker,
or Istio.
I just want to
upgrade this thing.
So I'm just going
to simulate that.
All I'm going to do is
change the version tag
of the same application
because it will
update the application itself.
So I'm going to go
from version 103
to version 104, just
written right here.
So if I go here, and I'm just
going to open a second window
so we can keep that
curl loop going.
It's a single command.
It's a container
builder command.
So it takes that
container, and it just
updates the version tag
of that same container.
But imagine in your mind
that you've actually
made some code changes, and then
you've updated the version tag.
So it's successfully uploaded.
And let's look at what's
happening in Spinnaker.
So this is my app.
That's the same
application that's running.
I've already done some
iterations to that.
And you can see that the last
iteration was version 103.
So I've set the trigger to kick
this pipeline off every time
the version tag updates.
So let's look at that pipeline.
And that pipeline look--
it's a very simple pipeline.
And you'll notice
there's two roads,
and they both look very
identical because it's just
deploying to east and
central at the same time.
So the first thing
it does is it deploys
the new version as canary to
both clusters with one pod.
Then it tests the canary.
And the way it does that
is it just simply downloads
a curl utility, BusyBox,
and just curls that service.
And if it's up, great.
And then it stops,
and then there's
a manual judgment
stage where it says,
do we want to promote
this to production?
And then when we say yes, it
promotes it to production.
And the way it gets
triggered is just down here.
You can see it's a web server.
And every time this tag
changes, this v tag changes,
go ahead and trigger it.
So if we go back, you can see
that the pipeline has already
triggered for 1.0.4.
And each of these
boxes is representing
each of those stages.
So the first two boxes are
central and east canary.
The next two boxes are testing
the central and east canary.
And then it stopped
at that fifth box.
If I just kind of
hover over that,
you can see that it's
asking me to hit Continue.
So at this point,
what's happening is
I have four pods of version
1.0.3 deployed as production.
And then I have one pod
of version 1.0.4 deployed
as canary.
So let's look at
our Cloud Shell.
And what you notice
right off the bat
is that we're still
going to production.
And that's because I have Istio
installed on this cluster.
And I've explicitly said
that send 100% of the traffic
to production.
So again, I'm a developer.
I have safely deployed this
thing with a single command.
I didn't have to
worry about Kubernetes
deployments or Spinnaker.
But now I wanted to
send some traffic to it.
And just for the sake of the
demo, what I'll do is I'll
send 100% of the
traffic to canary.
So I'm just going to
copy a route rule.
I'm going to delete
the route rule that
says send 100% to
production, and then I'm
going to implement another
route rule that says send
100% of the traffic to canary.
And if we look at
that route rule,
it's a very simple route
rule that just says,
look at that label
on that deployment.
And if that label
says stack canary,
just go ahead and send
100% of the traffic over.
And now if we go back,
we should shortly
see that thing move to 1.0.4.
And I don't need to worry
about calling a networking
admin or something.
And now 100% of the
traffic is going there.
And then now I can
control these waits.
And then perhaps I want to
send, you know, 5%, 10%, 20%
of the traffic without
talking to anybody.
So let's say--
I mean, just to show
you another example,
so let's say we
want to send 50/50.
So I can go back.
I can delete the 100 canary
rule and just put a 50/50 rule.
And if we look at what
our route rule looks
like now, basically by
using the magic of labels
and saying anything with
the label of stack prod,
send 50% of the
traffic, anything
with the label of stack canary,
send 50% of the traffic.
If we go back to
that now, you'll
start seeing that traffic
kind of go back and forth.
So let's say that
we're happy with this.
The ideal state is,
I want to go back
to 100% to production traffic.
So again, I can just
delete that 50/50 rule
and put that 100%
production traffic back in.
Now I'm happy with
my deployment.
I'm going to go ahead
and hit Continue.
And I'm going to promote
version 1.0.4 to production.
So those last two
boxes are essentially
doing a Kubernetes deployment
backed by the same service,
and they're deploying
four pods of that.
And while they're
deploying, we can actually
look at that application and
what it looks like today.
And so this is in the middle
of it deploying to production.
So we can see that
version 1.0.4,
there's one pod
deployed as canary.
And then in production,
I'm starting
to now create another
deployment for version 1.0.4.
But in the same screen, I can
see it tearing down the canary
and putting a new version
up until it's ready.
These are going to be red until
it waits for every single pod
to be ready before
it makes them green.
So let's go back
to our pipeline.
And let's just make sure
this last one finishes.
And that is the central one.
And once the central
one finishes,
what we're hoping
and expecting to see
is that version
1.0.4, first of all,
becomes prod, the new prod.
And then 100% of the
traffic goes there.
Of course, that one
is the one that's
taking a little bit of time.
So right now, you can see
that the difference here
from the start of the demo
was we had 1.0.3 as prod.
Then we had 1.0.4 as canary.
And now we have 1.0.4 as prod.
So just using Spinnaker
and Istio and Kubernetes
together, from a developer's
experience perspective,
I just want to
deploy my workload.
And I want it to
safely go from testing
to canary to production.
And then I want to
be able to manipulate
how I want that traffic routed.
So I was able to show that.
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
So that was the demo.
And thank you so
much for your time.
That's all I had.
I know we have
about seven minutes.
So I will take some questions
until they cut me off.
So if there's any
questions, please come up.
Otherwise, thank you
so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]